21 de outubro de 2015
o futuro chegou o futuro chegou o futuro
chegou
como será o amanhã não se preocupando
vou cantar só lembrar porque quando eu
vim para cá eu fiquei pensando por que
que a gente fala tanto de futuro porque
a gente quer saber o que a gente está
buscando o que a gente tá querendo
entender o ser humano não é de hoje
procura indagar pesquisar receber
iluminações sobre como será amanhã e
porque afinal de contas eu tenho pelo
menos três ideias sobre isso
a primeira delas é por que o futuro pode
significar pra gente é algo como um
sentido pode ser sentido
o que quer dizer o futuro é um sentido
no sentido nascente direção certa pra
onde eu vou daqui para adiante eu tô
aqui mas eu tô aqui pra que eu tô aqui
pra seguir adiante e se adiante o futuro
o futuro é sentido mas se pode ser
sentido também como explicação eu tô
aqui desse jeito mas tem que ter um
sentido
o sentido é que a vida deve ser melhor
será o sentido é que eu vou chegar lá
o sentido é que é tudo vai mudar para
mais para melhor o futuro pode ser
também razão não há razão no sentido de
a cenoura na frente do coelho do burro
o estímulo que fazem de ram a gente
passar adiante seguir adiante porque
agora agora talvez não seja tão bom
agora talvez eu não tenha todas as
respostas
agora talvez eu não saiba tudo o que eu
preciso saber
o que eu acho que eu preciso saber a
razão pela qual busca o futuro é por
essa razão e é isso que me faz mover ea
razão por que pode ser razão também no
sentido de explicação não é que eu faço
eu faço isso que eu faço aqui agora
por isso pelo futuro é minha razão eu
estou pensando mais adiante as coisas
aqui não estão mais ou menos coisas
estão mais ou menos tão esquisitas
possam estar gostando posso estar
insegura posso estar preocupado após
achar que tá esquisito para o
palestrante americano falou as coisas as
coisas não são fáceis as coisas não tão
boas
as perguntas às indagações dos riscos
são enormes então o futuro pode
significar essa razão essa explicação eu
faço porque eu tenho que superar e não é
de hoje que a gente se move como eu
disse tá sempre se movendo buscando essa
superação ser humano busca superar busca
esse futuro como forma de dar o salto
já faz muito tempo e porque a gente faz
isso que nos faz ninguém disse que o
futuro está ali a gente que saiu criando
essa idéia de futuro eo futuro está ali
pra quê porque o futuro da lipor pra
quem porquê porque agora aqui agora a
gente doce cento suficiente
a gente se sente frágil pequeno inseguro
a gente se sente talvez incompleto
a gente se sente vulnerável e essa
vulnerabilidade sintetizada por tudo que
a gente tem de insegurança de problema
de dor sofrimento desconhecido
é nessa lista de coisas que não era
beleza não tem um monte que nos assusta
mais que tudo e essa coisa e cientes e
chama morte
eu penso no futuro porque o futuro me dá
esse elo que isso que os faz com que eu
sobrepuje que o salto sobre a ideia da
morte possa me projetar verdade fantasia
ilusão não sei bem se projeta para além
essa morte que alguns filósofos a chama
de alteridade radical esse outro que eu
não conheço esse outro que nem aceito
esse o
eu não quero ela me assusta ea gente
pequeno e frágil e insegura que a gente
quer se não projetar o futuro para ir
além e a gente projetou a gente projetou
muita coisa a gente transformou a vida e
mais do que essa resistência natural a
gente transformou a vida é a ideia
pensamento projeto desenvolvimento
nesse processo a gente construiu coisas
artefatos programas software e hardware
de todo tipo empreendimentos a vida se
transformou a isso hoje em dia a gente
não come a gente olha a gente ingere
proteína vitaminas sais minerais não é a
gente não vai ali e dar uma volta não
passei nem a gente faz joguem tantos
minutos respiram tanto tempo a passada
tudo controlado a vida virou isso no
entanto a gente segue projetando
projetando projetando tá bom tá ruim não
estou discutindo é isso que a gente faz
é essa ideia a ideia do futuro traz isso
a gente busca o futuro pois porque agora
pode ser o esse agora pode ser o agora
final ea gente projetou projetou criou
foi na vem cá criou coisa imaginou coisa
a gente chegou de volta para o futuro
ministro é hoje 21 de outubro de 2015 o
futuro chegou e foi legal
pensa sobre isso porque o futuro além de
rasgar de de sentido além de motivo o
futuro também pode significar para nós
promessa e compromisso a gente prometeu
que a vida devia ser bem melhor será
essa promessa foi lançada a gente fez
todos os esforços
a gente tentou de tudo o que rolou de
tudo inventou de tudo e não chegamos
aqui 21 de outubro de 2015
a promessa foi cumprida o futuro chegou
e foi bom pra você
o santos falava pra nós aqui de um filme
um filme super bacana eu quero citar de
novo porque ele foi um presente que ele
me deu na nossa conversa antes de chegar
aqui gattaca quem não viu pode lá na
internet
tudo está lá né é um filme de 1997 você
não se lembra é uma história que começa
assim no futuro não muito distante
a nossa vida vai ser definida pelo pela
nosso dna
nesse filme a história muito resumo bem
resumido fala história de que nesse
futuro não muito distante a humanidade
vai ser de dois tipos aqueles concebidos
com base no processo entre aspas natural
aquele processo biológico conhecido até
então aquele que todo mundo conhece nem
papai mamãe juntinho do outro beijo um
abraço nela fez neném e a gente nasce né
essa é uma ideia um processo de
concepção dos seres humanos mas nesse
futuro não tão distante que gattaca traz
um outro processo é aquele em que a
gente programa a gente define que a
gente move as bases do dna para criar o
ser humano perfeito nesse futuro aqueles
concebidos daquele jeito papai e mamãe
como eu fui
são considerados não válidos parece
aqueles inválidos que se definitivamente
os não válidos e os perfeitos os
concebidos sob regras de planejamento
serão considerados válidos e o filme é
sobre esse cara que nasceu não válido
mas ele tem um sonho de ocupar as
posições dos válidos ele quer ser
astronauta ele quer brilhar ele sabe que
tem um talento e o enredo se desenvolve
a partir dos estratagemas das coisas que
ele faz das ações que lhes faz o que ele
faz das buscas que ele tem para superar
a sua condição de não vale se
transformar num vale do astronauta como
ele sonho e esse futuro e esse futuro de
gata que aparece um pouco o futuro de
hoje parece um pouco com o futuro que a
gente tem agora 21 de outubro de 2015
parece um pouco porque porque gata que
atrás de si um futuro em que as coisas
as barreiras são bastante fixas e olha
aí fora
ora o noticiário lê o jornal e a notícia
na internet
as barreiras são duras assim
possibilidades são enormes e emigrante
hoje em dia tentando entrar na europa
nos conta estudos barreiras são muito
difíceis e esse é o momento em que gata
aparece
se realiza o futuro chegou chegou mas
chegou e não tá bom
chegou desse jeito mais gata também
também traz outra mensagem se você olhar
bem o personagem
aquele não vale do que a sexta o
astronauta dá através de gata carlos
mandou outra mensagem ea mensagem da
insurgência
a mensagem do inconformismo a mensagem
da criatividade para a superação a
mensagem de que a vida deve ser bem
melhores será mas deve ser para quem
existe deve ser pra qualquer um
essa é uma das mensagens de gattaca que
está aqui agora
com base nisso a pergunta feita pelo tex
do iuan para 21 de outubro de 2015 é e
daqui para adiante
a gente tem essas barreiras a gente tem
essas violências
a gente tem essas guerras a gente tem
essas mortes ea morte aquela que a gente
teme toda temperando a morte está aí mas
a gente tenta a nanotecnologia a
esperança os projetos a gente vai à lua
ea marte a gente sonha a gente traz a
comunicação a gente queria linguagem
universal
a gente usa técnico tecnologia a
tecnologia fragmento mas a a tecnologia
nos leva também para mais longe daqui eu
falo com alguém que nem seu nome nem
onde está mas eu sei que lá do outro
lado do mundo fala agora neste exato
momento
é verdade que a gente ouviu aqui que a
gente fala em isolamento a gente precisa
chegar mais perto mas a gente vai longe
ea gente sabe o caminho onde a gente
pode encontrar essa pessoa
então esse futuro é complexo e vai nos
levar para onde é que vai dar nisso
gattaca traz essa terceira mensagem
depois daqui pra onde a gente vai o
futuro do futuro pode ter vários
caminhos pode ter esse caminho entre o
medo da morte medo da dor medo do
sofrimento uso exacerbado da tecnologia
sem controle o poder desmesurado nos
leva ao que de pior
a humanidade pode produzir
pode nos levar ao isolamento ao
sofrimento a dor pode nos trazer aquilo
que a gente tentava afastar a gente
queria afastar a morte e ela traz forte
e imponente impotente assustadora
esse futuro agora pode ser esse agente
que a gente a gente queria viver
tranquilamente mas a gente produz as
coisas do jeito que a gente traz mais
violência enquanto mais violência mas a
arma quanto mais armas polícia quanto
mais polícia mais insegurança mais
violência mais armas polícia mas guerra
mas exerce a gente fica nesse ciclo
vicioso
mas pode ter um outro lado pode ter
outro lado pode ser com isso tudo que a
gente tem na mão todas as tecnologias
todas as consciências todas as
comunicações
todas as possibilidades todos os desejos
e sonhos pode nos levar para outro lado
para outra direção pode nos levar
na direção daquilo que está dentro de
mim daquela potência que lhe poder de
fazer a escolha
eu posso escolher e na direção do
imperativo ético de um filósofo é claro
que esse filósofo era nem alemão que
dizia é preciso que haja uma humanidade
então a gente diz não às fronteiras as
barreiras às guerras e tenta buscar o
encontro a aproximação à comunicação a
possibilidade de superação da diferença
uma humanidade a gente pode abrir mão da
violência e tentar construir a irmandade
a proximidade a cooperação a relação
internacional que mais além
essa língua universal que a gente pode
falar é a língua do encontro
esse futuro pode chegar até aí a gente
tem dois caminhos duas possibilidades a
gente pode ser o da guerra
o da perda de tudo a gente pode ser o da
conquista
aquele que pode construir outra coisa a
gente pode ser aqueles que não tinha
direitos àqueles que dizem pode ser esse
futuro não vale do que a gente só tem
medo de esperança mas a gente pode ser
esse futuro da conquista onde aquele ser
que lá no passado era um ser condenado a
inexistente construiu a noção de direito
construiu para si para o
mundo nós o conceito de deter direitos
construir o direito de ter direitos
construiu a possibilidade de dar de
lutar por direitos
construiu as ferramentas para exercício
desse direito
construiu a possibilidade e se projetar
no mundo como ser cidadão cidadania e
irmandade qualquer que seja o nome
construir essa possibilidade de se
imaginar um outro futuro mas nessa nessa
conversa nessa mudança que a gente fica
descobrindo é que essa esse futuro do
futuro nos traz uma questão uma questão
que o desmascaramento da ideia de futuro
3d não desmascará o futuro a gente não
dá o passo seguinte porque o futuro e se
não uma ilusão porque a gente só existe
aqui e agora
daqui a pouco eu posso não ser daqui a
pouco eu posso não está mas essa escolha
de aqui agora é que torna o futuro
fascinantes mas torna presente o aqui
agora o momento da responsabilidade
essa escolha a era do medo à era da
responsabilidade o futuro do futuro
tá aí tá nessa flexão nesse atrito nessa
disputa
o futuro dessas futuro está nessa
escolha e quem escolhe o governo e
escolhe a polícia quem escolhe a guerra
não escolhe sou eu quem escolhe é você
o futuro do futuro é um lugar da sua
responsabilidade e essa responsabilidade
só se realiza aqui e agora
muito obrigado